when you think back on all the stunts
you've done
which is the one that before you did it
you were like oh i don't know about this
one
we were doing uh cap two winter soldier
and we were out in long beach on a
aircraft carrier
so however many stories above sea level
the the boat is which is i mean it's so
it's like 150 feet up
right there was a crane on the deck
which was another 150 feet up so you
were probably 300 feet up from the
from the water and basically we had to
do is clip into the crane
and and and they they dropped us so that
it looked like we were flying onto the
boat
and i wasn't gonna do it i said i'm not
doing that let my
let my guy do it i'm not doing it and
scarlett johansson said well i'm doing
it
yep so she went and did it and then i
had to do it
i think in the movie i fly in behind her
and uh
she didn't but i had [ __ ] in my pants
because i was that afraid
yeah and it was pitch black it was
nighttime
right so i i i first of all
i could never do that and second of all
but what i can i can only imagine what
it's like on set when scarlett says
she's going to do it
scarlett i mean it's like you know okay
scarlet i guess i guess i'm going to do
it too
you know um the only other thing i did
uh that i that was stupid is and it
wasn't a stunt
but when i when i did uh the movie the
david air movie with gyllenhaal and pena
yeah we were the uh gyllenhaal had this
great idea that he was gonna get tased
so he could feel what it was feeling
like and i'm like i'm not doing that
you're stupid
and then natalie martinez beautiful
natalie martinez said well i'm gonna do
it and i'm like
mother now i gotta do it because i'm
you know that guy and it was miserable
yeah so yes
mostly i just fight you know mostly i'll
do all my own fighting i'll do my own
driving
as long as i'm not driving off something
i try not to jump too much
i don't i don't like jumping off things